have you heard yellow wolf's rock album
i love it it is so [ __ ] good yes
making me a believer thing is crazy the
video is crazy oh my god the radio
record everything i think i told him i
was like uh this feels like
it just feels like
big feels big arena rock yes old school
arena rock yeah it feels like i told him
this the other day i was like i feel
like you should be opening up for like
[ __ ] motley crew or [ __ ] like the
rolling stones like this [ __ ] sounds
like you should be opening for the
rolling stones it's like big [ __ ] big
[ __ ] it's so [ __ ] good and i thought
that was dope for him to do that
to get that loose with that right after
coming off you know
the mao zero project and then the caskey
[ __ ]
yeah shout out to uh shooter jennings
sometimes why
that is struggles brother struggles
uncle struggle okay struggles uncle
shooter is what we call them would you
in struggle do another joint we're doing
another one now you are we're we'll be
putting those out until we're [ __ ]
like
grumpy old men
are the grumpy old men movies that'll be
me and struggle putting out projects
when we're 70. i remember the yeah yeah
the grumpy old man was a i remember the
what was the guy's name he one had white
hair and one had that big [ __ ] nose
yeah i forgot the names of it but it's
like well that'll be me in struggle
we'll be like
putting out projects yeah he makes me
feel really fat every time i see him on
instagram listen you want to [ __ ] you
imagine how i feel he looks like a
[ __ ] action figure yeah he's [ __ ]
yeah no i [ __ ] hate him i'm like bro
yeah no i've seen him he's just walking
around with his shirt off [ __ ] doing
he looks like he's a professional cage
fighter he does what the [ __ ] is
happening with you yeah and i couldn't
be doing more of the opposite i'm just
like [ __ ] eating sandwiches and
drinking myself into a coma every night
and [ __ ] waking up with a hangover
and having to eat my way through it the
next day you know saying or blowing
[ __ ] cocaine boogers out i'm having
like the total opposite
moment of my life and struggles having
right now